these are the perfect shoes for lazy
people like me we rolled over the
friends to meet maker Paul Siobhan and
his wheelie need invention second law
reflection Co the transport not reveal
the deepest part video LD Jean 11 euros
kuvikavi beaucoup SOT written Epico
Hasid velu judicata net collision AV
pocket montevideo L a dog ensures
complete the Bocuse Italy Tapia would on
but how do these rockers prepare power
forward these may look like normal
roller skates but they're actually
electronic smart skates when you walk
normally you're applying a complex
series of forces between your feet and
the ground simply strapping a bunch of
motors and wheels to a human foot just
ain't gonna work
instead sensors monitor the different
forces exerted by the foot during the
course of the step and an on-board
computer controls the power to the
motors so the user can pick up and put
down their feet like in normal walking
and the wheels respond by pushing
forward
the software in the skates will speed up
or slow down the wheels based on how
fast you're walking so if you're in a
hurry you just take faster steps and the
skates will speed up to these devices
even have a mode for enabling the wear
to safely navigate stairs by locking the
wheels if the sensors detect force is
only on the ball of the foot the motors
turn on las casas Joey vamos Elkanah
vacate appeared on Mme de Hugo Chavez
curve a pivot no Canadian sensation
edition market hezekiah
aesthetically second is no devil girl
cotton Afeni the conservable machine or
Malmo on an obsession the new pure von
Sydow the curiosity
these skates are step in the right
direction
wow it looks like you're on a roll